time now for morning rounds our Medical
News of the weekend a look at a new
hospital meant to treat diseases and
ease the minds of parents and children
at a facility in palo alto california a
top priority was to create a special
environment for young patients with
comforts amusements and distractions to
make a hospital stay easier to handle
John Blackstone took a tour a playground
is a key feature of a groundbreaking new
Children's Hospital at Stanford
University Christopher Dawes is proud of
all the details and it bears yeah this
is a photo op for the families
Dawes heads the newly opened Lucile
Packard Children's Hospital at Stanford
University we have an outdoor patio for
every floor
Karina Garcia is one of the first
patients how many things are you hooked
up to anyway her recovery from surgery
for serious intestinal problems has been
made easier in a hospital designed from
the ground up to serve young patients
and their families I like when she is
able to take a walk with a nurse and her
mother lucila karena seeks out the
animal sculptures that dot the hallways
she was particularly delighted to
discover the cow made out of toys what
difference does it make having something
like this it's cool it's like
distracting it's like whoa it gets like
your mind off like the sickness and
medicine you're just like oh my god
admiring the eye for 2 year-old Olivia
Casillas and her parents Josie and Erin
there is no better distraction than the
story room it's huge
interactive screen there's another scene
where you can wave your arms around and
the seaweed moves and the fish interact
with you
[Music]
it makes long Hospital days easier for
Olivia who in her short life has
undergone 13 surgeries and it's all
about finding new things for her to do
there's always kids in here I think it's
awesome because not only are they here
because they're sick but they get to be
kids too
the hospital was mostly funded by the
Lucile Packard Foundation created by the
wife of Hewlett Packard's co-founder in
her view and in ours that it's so
important to think about it the hospital
from the kids perspective David Orr is
Lucile Packard grandson it's not just a
kind of sterile institution with echoing
white hallways we've decorated the room
a potential scary procedure like a CT
scan is filled with distractions for
examples twinkling stars on the ceiling
wallpaper on the walls to make it look
like the beach or at San Francisco but
one simple feature seems most
significant almost every room is private
and includes a couch that makes into a
bed and tremendous difference I see the
bed yeah because I had to spend many
days more a hundred days in the hospital
Karina's mother never leaves like she
stayed with me every single admission
she slept every single day and she
hasn't ever left my side so I'm like
very lucky and thankful for my mom the
technology the art the outdoors may all
be good for healing but love helps too
for CBS this morning Saturday John
Blackstone Palo Alto California